ever since chat GPT came out the tech
landscape hasn't been the same as if
it's suddenly hit by a burst of
enthusiasm or a fomo the titans of the
tech world have a rapidly assembled of
massive AI departments and begun working
Facebook Amazon Apple Google and
basically everyone else has embarked on
a race to finally outdo one another and
to come out as the Supreme Victor their
goal simple create the next big thing
the next YouTube the next Google the
next Instagram they have followed an
unprecedented amount of resources into
Research Laboratories compensation and
marketing Hardware software and
everything else required to bring these
remarkable Innovations to market the
promise of ai's potential was simply too
enticing to ignore self-evolving
algorithms human-like machines
unbelievable automation but most
importantly Unthinkable riches and
control the reality though is that fomo
has blinded these Giants to a simple yet
glaring truth they have already lost Ai
and pouring hundreds of billions into a
lost battle isn't going to change
anything let me explain
[Music]
in the stock market there is a famous
saying past performance is not an
indicator of future results AKA just
because a stock has been performing well
does not mean that it will continue to
perform well most investors say this
tongue-in-cheek they know that it's true
but they continue to invest in companies
and funds largely because they are
performed well in the past companies are
even more susceptible to this logical
fallacy as they have been directly
rewarded for such behavior in the past
the only reason they got so big in the
first place is because they gambled a
big on their hero products whether
that's the iPhone or Google or Whatsapp
they went against the grain and bet it
all remember how much criticism Facebook
received for spending 19 billion on
WhatsApp back in 2014 this gamble ended
up paying off but let's not forget what
it was a gamble each time these
companies win a gamble they're more
inclined to think that they can down
dominate any industry they want if they
just spend enough money but this notion
is fundamentally flawed and you don't
have to look much further than meta
after making Deca billion dollar Bets
with WhatsApp and Instagram and seeing
them pay off Zuckerberg felt confident
to start betting in the hundreds of
billions with the metaverse and I think
we all remember how that turned out but
the metaverse is merely their most
publicized failure meta's list of
failure is just far larger than just
that take poke for example in the early
2010s after seeing how well Snapchat was
doing and feeling to acquire Snapchat
Facebook decided to launch a clone
called poke the premise seems
straightforward leveraged their vast
user base and existing infrastructure to
launch a rival app which should have
been a slam dunk against Snapchat but
Pope would end up flopping so hard that
Facebook would end up deleting poke from
the app store without even publicly
mentioning it jump forward a few years
and the Zuckerberg would start betting
on Space the apparent next big thing he
was going to build this Grand drone
internet until he quietly shut down that
as well the metaverse gamble followed as
did bets on AI and most recently the
threads Endeavor I mean with threads
their daily active users was literally
down over 80 percent within just a month
of launch with each and every one of
these products Zuckerberg was trying to
create the next big thing up next to Big
social media the next big Space Project
the next big VR project and the next big
AI project but
every time they miserably failed this
isn't to say that the sector itself
failed though Snapchat has 400 million
users Twitter has 370 million users
starlink is doing great and someone will
eventually win VR it's simply that that
someone wasn't Facebook the reality is
that Facebook has only launched one next
big thing product in their entire
history and that was their original
product Facebook they had two successful
Acquisitions Instagram and WhatsApp but
that pretty much sums up the entire
company everything else they tried was a
complete failure this isn't a jab
against Facebook as it's true with all
of their peers as well when was the last
time that Google or Apple or Amazon
actually launched something that was
even comparable to their hero product
Google has arguably had the most number
of successful products but at this point
it's been over a decade since they
launched a winner as well the reason is
obvious it's simply ridiculously hard to
replicate the success of something like
Facebook or YouTube even for companies
that have already already done it once
or twice this brings us back to the
original statement past performance is
not an indicator of future results just
because Facebook launched a successful
social media 20 years ago and the Google
launched a successful search engine 25
years ago does not mean that they have a
better chance of winning AI today in
fact I would actually argue that it
leaves them worse off let me explain
[Music]
everyone is so quick to point out all of
the advantages enjoyed by these Tech
Giants they commanded the finest
Engineers possess unparalleled
infrastructure possess seemingly
Limitless capital and boasts extensive
reach among other assets but rarely do
people consider these companies a bigger
shortfall an incomprehensible amount of
baggage aside from Wall Street and big
Pharma big Tech is likely the most hated
industry in the world people see them as
monopolies with way too much power
control and influence not to mention the
privacy concerns only a vocal minority
voiced their concerns about these
companies or go as far as ditching
WhatsApp or Gmail but that isn't to say
that everyone else is happy with these
platforms and likely the best example of
this is with YouTube creators when a
YouTuber starts using too much clickbait
or starts selling out too much only a
vocal minority will call them out
everyone else will just be less inclined
to watch their next video when you
compound this over months and years
that's how you end up with a dead
channel it's the same thing with big
tech people aren't going to ditch Gmail
just because Google is notorious for
collecting data or implementing
anti-consumer friendly policies but when
they eventually get the chance to choose
between Bard and chat GPD they're gonna
choose chat GPT every day of the week in
fact I would argue that this bias is the
number one reason that otherwise great
products don't take off take threads for
example one of the biggest critiques of
threads is that it's just a ripoff of
Twitter but that's quite a funny
argument because that was never a
showstopper before Facebook itself
wasn't the Pioneer in the realm of
social media thus Friendster and the
Myspace ring a bell and what about
Google is there a single thing that
they've launched that's not a rip-off
they didn't create search engines or
email or video sharing or browsers or
smartphones or really anything they just
made things better and that was enough
recent products like threads and Bart
however appeared to be judged more by
their perceived lack of originality than
by their actual merits honestly this
phenomenon has more to do with Optics
than product authenticity imagine if
threads was a startup if threads was a
startup the Optics would be completely
different threads would have been seen
as the Valiant Underdog taking on the
once great Twitter that was ruined by
Elon Musk but since threads is from
Facebook people perceive it as oh great
greedy Facebook is trying to expand
their Monopoly into yet another sector
woohoo you could almost see this playing
out in real time after threads launched
everyone checked it out just to see what
all the hype was about but no one really
resonated with the product or story and
this is why it's so dangerous for these
big tech companies to enter the AI scene
more than likely they're just gonna burn
an extraordinary amount of money and end
up losing anyway in fact this trend has
already begun with Bard the common
sentiment around the board is that chat
GPT was the OG revolutionary product and
that Bard was just copy pasted chat gbt
but this is completely false Google has
been working on AI for longer than open
ai's entire existence now you might be
saying oh well Google probably wasn't as
focused as open AI but this is also
completely false in total openai has
raised 11.3 billion dollars which is an
insane amount for a startup but do you
want to guess how much Google has
invested into AI maybe 20 billion 40
billion well it's actually upwards of
200 billion dollars Google has literally
been investing open ai's entire funding
into AI every six months for the past
decade to come up with Bard but
unfortunately for Google it looks like
Bard is going to end up as the next Bing
while attachepita ends up as the next
Google the bottom line is that people
have already made up their mind about
big Tech so outspending the competition
isn't going to allow these companies to
come out on top but then
what's the solution
well the solution is easy Fang must come
to terms with reality the reality that
AI will only yield a limited number of
true winners and statistically speaking
it's highly improbable that the big Tech
Giants will emerge as one of these
winners despite their vast resources
combine this with the overwhelmingly
negative public sentiment against these
companies and it becomes damn near
impossible for a thing to win AI so
should they just sit back and watch as
their fortunes crumble thanks to
up-and-coming AI products well of course
not that would be brain dead Behavior
but if sitting back is a bad idea and
going all in is also a bad idea what in
the world are they supposed to do
well easy instead of trying to strike
gold themselves they should be selling
the shuffles this is exactly what Nvidia
has been doing and I mean the results
speak for themselves Nvidia was
originally a consumer brand focused on
selling gpus to Gamers they screwed up
their PR with Gamers when they started
embracing cryptocurrency miners Gamers
felt like Nvidia betrayed them and that
Nvidia was just milking Gamers and yada
yada
when AI started gaining steam Nvidia
could have easily tried to make their
own in-house consumer AI platform they
had all the tech and money to do so but
instead they chose to bet on something
far more consistent and reliable selling
shovels now it doesn't matter to them
who wins the AI game it could be Apple
or Google or Facebook or open AI or some
startup no one has ever heard of it
doesn't matter because they're all using
Nvidia gpus in this sense Nvidia has
already won Ai and secured their future
within the new era without actually
having to take the massive gamble of
creating the next big thing the same
thing can be said about Microsoft about
10 years ago they decided that they were
gonna be a back-end company focused on
supporting great Solutions as opposed to
creating great Solutions the result well
after 17 years of stagnation Microsoft
with nearly 7x within four years now of
course supporting these Solutions won't
be as local device creating them but the
probability of success is also more like
90 as opposed to one in a million also
for the record supporting AI is already
insanely lucrative Google seems to be
recognizing this paradigm shift as
they've started focusing more on
expanding their Cloud business rather
than slowly launching consumer-centric
products Facebook on the other hand is
still going all out on gambles whether
that's the metaverse AI or threads
it's the same case with many of the
other companies at the top as well as
they've all been blinded by fomo and all
they're gonna have to show for it in 5
or 10 years is a slew of Forgotten
products and hundreds of billions of
dollars Less in the bank the problem is
that much of big Tech is trying to buy
naked calls on AI when the smarter
solution is to just sell puts by
offering the foundational tools and
support necessary for the AI landscape
to flourish and to laugh all the way to
the bank but that's just what I think if
you'd like to learn about how AI got to
this point check out this video but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one
thank you